gets a surprisingly long sentence for an
unusual case when we compare it to
other crimes for example racially
aggravated common assault that carries a
maximum sentence of two years
yet stephen bouquet has been sentenced
for five years
and three months for killing killing
cats around
brighton the 54 year old security guard
stabbed 16 cats between
end of 2018 and june 2019 and of those
16 cats
nine unfortunately did die and seven
were left
injured so he's been convicted of 16
offenses of criminal damage to the cats
and also for possession of a knife which
was found in a search of his home
and during these searches police also on
his laptop discovered he'd repeatedly
been accessing
a website relating to missing cats in
the area he'd also viewed numerous dog
killing cat related videos
and had two photos of dead cats now cctv
footage that you're seeing was pivotal
for um
to him being caught it was actually set
up by an owner who had
become victim to his crimes and in the
footage he pursues nine-month-old
hendricks who then
brandishes weapon from his bag and then
attacks the cat and then walks
off now when he was interviewed by
police bokeh
said he'd had no knowledge about
anything that had happened apart from
what he had been reading online let's
take a watch
of part of that interview for what we're
talking about
do you like cats yeah yeah yeah i've
always
i've always been friendly like um some
no threat of animals
if you put yourself over as a threat
they'll like scratch and
do whatever you like they come up to me
like in the smoke and i
send them on their way no issues with
cats dogs or anything like that
now the jury heard from a number of
owners
affected by the attacks at lucy kenwood
she said she spent 5 000 pounds on vet
bills trying to save her cat which
unfortunately did later die
due to the stab wounds and andrea
williams said she was inconsolable
after losing her cat he initially went
missing
and was later found in a garden so this
sentencing i think
for the victims is going to bring some
closure and safety for the community